欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,接着我们来讲第二种通过关键词去选品的方式
就是通过涨幅关键词去挖掘产品的品类和款式直接去打造爆品
我们来打开后台看一下,比如说我们在选词参谋这里点了一下
但是我们没有做任何的关键词搜索
我们直接看我们的热池榜
这里的热池榜跟趋势榜, 通常我们是按周来看的, 或者是每周来看一次, 去挖掘一些新的款式, 新的增长的热搜词, 这样我们能够覆盖的流量更加广, 而且很有可能就是同行也没有发现这些流量词, 你可以提前去把这些词应用到你店铺里面的新的潜力品, 或者是直接去重新选品,
去发产品, 那么也能够快速的获得这部分流量
这个板块非常容易被忽视的一个板块
首先我们来看热池吧
你可以按照内幕去搜索
可以从更细的维度去看
最近你们这个内幕有哪些属性的词
或者是相关的产品值在增长
你可以通过这些去挖掘一些产品
那么这个挖掘的词跟我们刚才讲的那个关键词指数里面的挖掘的方法是一样的
这个是通过具体的品类
再到细分里面的产品
那么趋势榜呢
就是通过品类跟词的一个匹配度去选品
比如说你看这里这个图
这种这个关键词匹配的是哪些产品
看这个图你看它有样式增长
我们去看这些产品的款式
去选这些款式匹配上这一类词
然后再去推广去打造报品
这种的成功概率是非常大的
你看我去找这个相关的词的款式选好了之后
我再去把这些款式相匹配的涨幅上涨的词来组合标题
再去打造这些产品是非常容易见效的
而且是非常快就能拿到结果的
很可能你推广两天都有可能有询盘
这些我都试过我都用过这些方法
选品的话, 你没有必要去发一些没有被验证过的款式, 你可以直接就用它们相似的款式去发产品, 直接就推广就可以了, 我们这种选品的方式都是在已知别人是爆品的前提下, 去利用新类型的关键词去覆盖这些爆品, 和同行做差异化的推广, 来获得更多的一个流量, 所以这种选品成功的概率就非常大,
根本就不需要我们再去测试和验证了
我们直接就是在优秀同行的基础上直接用他们的就可以了
这个就是通过涨幅值去挖掘产品的品类和款式去打造爆品
那么它的一个具体的步骤也是跟我们刚才讲的这些步骤是一样的
那么如果你不是特别清楚
那么你可以对照着这个步骤直接去按照这个流程选品
然后直接去推广就可以了
这是比较简单
而且不需要你做什么数据统计表
也不需要你去收集什么数据
我们这个方法
其实就是利用已知的一些热门款式
去充分利用最近上涨的一些蓝海词去匹配
就直接能够打造这些类爆品
就直接能够覆盖更多的人群
通过覆盖这一类人群让我们的这一类产品跟同行形成差异化去打造爆品
如果你还没有用过这种方法那么你可以现在开始去尝试使用
只要你把细节做到位是非常容易见效的
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见